thank you
[Music]
hello everyone
welcome to Capcom Spotlight where we'll
provide updates on our upcoming games
stay tuned until the end to hear the
latest on all of capcom's new titles
without any further delay here's the
first game
no matter what we're always connected
all 10 me like games in the Mega Man
Battle Network series are coming to
Nintendo switch PlayStation 4 and steam
Mega Man Battle Network Legacy
Collection launches April 14 2023
Lan it is netnavy Mega man.exe work
together to solve countless cyber crimes
in the real world as well as the
interconnected online cyber world
add battleships to your chip folder to
use in combat as you battle viruses on
the net
select multiple chips of the same type
and code each turn to create powerful
combinations
[Music]
we soon be getting a message from
director masakazu eguchi aka Mr famous
battle routine set up execute
hello everyone it's Mr famous
I'm excited to share the latest Battle
Network news with you all
first check out this video
[Music]
thank you
Mega Man Battle Network Legacy
Collection includes all 499 patch cards
from Battle Network 4 onwards that were
available only in Japan as physical
cards in Battle Network 4 5 and 6
players can enable or disable patch
cards
[Music]
multiplies the mega Buster's damage by
100 letting players enjoy the story and
speed up combat
you can turn this feature on or off at
any time during the story based on how
you want to play
[Music]
and don't worry
wolf mode is automatically turned off
for online net battling
that's all I have for you today
I've been Mr famous
thank you Mr famous
Mega Man Battle Network lazy collection
includes over 1 000 illustrations and
188 music tracks to enjoy in the gallery
with online play players can connect
with distant friends and Rivals to trade
battleships and net battle too
pre-orders are available now Mega Man
Battle Network Legacy Collection brings
all 10 Mainland games to Nintendo switch
PlayStation 4 and steam
[Music]
volume 1 and volume 2 will also be
available at launch
starting March 21st the English version
of Mega Man NT Warrior will be available
to watch for free
check the official website for more
information
[Music]
a new era of fighting games is upon us
Street Fighter 6 launches June 2nd 2023.
this is the latest edition of the series
that redefined the genre
in addition to fighting grounds where
the Pinnacle of genre defining battles
take place Street Fighter 6 includes
World Tour and immersive single-player
story mode and battle Hub an online
social space reminiscent of arcades
there are a number of new ways to play
Beyond just fighting
today we'll introduce the final color
commentator included in the game
play this video
foreign
[Music]
get it
foreign
actress Hikaru Takahashi is joining The
Fray bringing our lineup of play-by-play
and color commentators to a total of
eight real-time commentary matches the
in-game action and brings the
competitive thrill and excitement
straight to your home
subtitles for real-time commentary will
be supported in 13 languages
turn on rally support and the
commentators will cheer you on
creating a more personal experience
[Music]
Street Fighter 6 Launches on PlayStation
5 PlayStation 4 Xbox series X and Xbox
series s and steam on June 2nd 2023
pre-orders are now available along with
a limited number of pre-order bonuses
see the official website for details
we'll have more Street Fighter 6 updates
at a later date
[Music]
Capcom Pro Tour 2023 invites players
around the world to compete to be the
best
are you ready we're also proud to
announce the 2023 season will feature
Street Fighter 6.
to celebrate the game's release there
will be a special Prize Package this
season the first place winner of Capcom
cup will receive one million dollars the
total prize pool for the season will be
over 2 million dollars
we'd like to share some exciting Capcom
news
Capcom celebrates its 40th anniversary
this June as part of the celebration
we're opening a digital theme park
called Capcom Town we're planning to
construct a digital Museum and other
buildings the grand opening is June 12
2023.
please see this link for the latest
[Music]
Buffalo
a Capcom ID account is required to play
Resident Evil reverse exopril and use
the online features of Street Fighter 6.
[Music]
you can use this account with other
Capcom services and campaigns such as a
survey about today's Capcom Spotlight
we'll release more titles and services
compatible with Capcom ID soon register
now for Capcom ID
uristic EXO suits and dinosaurs class in
EXO primal
in this team-based action game players
suit up as EXO fighters who work for the
IBS Corporation
use a variety of unique EXO suits and
rigs to fit your play style and work
with teammates to combat hordes of
dinosaurs in Dino Survival let's take a
look at the latest trailer we have some
surprises in store so be sure to watch
to the end
in every war game Ace really is getting
pulled back three years into the past
back to 2014 right before the strativada
fails
you're a time traveler this is no random
outbreak Leviathan is intentionally
summoning them as cannon fodder for the
war game but why why repeat the same day
over and over
here
one of the first outbreaks
never found out more than that you know
she is delighted
in the island
[Applause]
in the past
okay you want to try talking to Paris at
you another one
[Music]
still handsome
oh
you're ready
another EXO fighter recruit right
welcome to ibius
laughs
what did you think we had a lot of new
info including the release date let's go
over it in detail
EXO Primal Launches on July 14th
[Music]
before that we'll be holding an open
beta test
in addition to the eight exosuits we've
previously introduced the two new suits
in today's trailer will also be playable
in the open beta test
experience the power of each exosuit for
yourself as your team faces off against
a wall of dinosaurs in Dino survival the
game's main mode
participants in the open beta test who
fill out a survey will also receive an
ibius metal charm that can be used in
the full game
please visit the official site for beta
test timing content and bonus item info
now I'd like to introduce the survival
pass reward system
as players acquire experience points in
the survival pass their survival pass
level goes up and they earn rewards
separate from player and suit levels
the survival pass includes a free tier
and a paid premium tier
purchasing the premium tier unlocks
access to special rewards including 19
Exo Suit skins and 10 weapon skins
here are some of the rewards
the deluxe edition includes the survival
pass season 1 Premium tier as an added
limited time bonus
exopril launches July 14 2023
pre-order bonuses are also available
please see the official site for details
on bonus items and the game
the latest EXO Primal news can be found
on the official website and social media
we'll have more for you soon
[Music]
beta test
use your powers of the Dead to uncover
the truth about your death
trick the classic mystery game from Ace
Attorney Creator shu takumi is being
reborn
the game release on June 30th 2023
one match in the dark corner of the city
a man named Sizzle is shot and killed
she reawakens as a soul and realizes
he's lost his memory and his life
[Music]
who was I who killed me
why did I have to die
these are the Mysteries he's trying to
solve with the powers of the Dead
Bissell has two basic abilities
using objects in the Ghost World
and then tricking them in the real world
a Hitman is after the red-headed Target
Lynn use the powers of the Dead to get
her out of wild predicaments
the key to changing fate Is possessing
and tricking all sorts of objects
the soul will face death in many forms
use the powers of the Dead to go back
four minutes before someone's death
changing their fate will change the
story
and that story must be linked in some
way to the mystery of sissel's death
this board includes updated high-res
Graphics increased frame rate and an
optimized user interface
[Music]
check out the new challenges feature
you can earn illustrations and music
from the game by needing certain
conditions
[Music]
in addition all 37 tracks from the game
have newly arranged versions
you can switch between the original and
new versions as you play
[Music]
hello everyone I'm Shu takumi the writer
and director of the original Ghost Trick
game
we're thrilled to share the release date
with you all I'm incredibly excited to
revisit Ghost Trick we had yasuma Sal
kitagawa from the great Ace Attorney
series handled the music
he did incredible work remastering the
original songs to match the new graphics
we've also added original music from
composer Masa Kazu tsugimori to
celebrate the new version of the game I
hope you enjoy these new songs
the story of Lost lives and lost memory
all in a single night
Ghost Trick will be reborn in high
resolution with new music on June 30th
2023 for Nintendo switch PlayStation 4
Xbox One and steam
pre-orders are now available check out
the official website for information
about the pre-order bonus
please stay tuned
[Music]
thank you
it's time to awaken your hunting Spirit
on even more platforms
Monster Hunter rise is now available for
Xbox series X and Xbox series s Xbox One
windows PlayStation 5 and Playstation 4.
please watch this video with information
about the latest promotions
[Music]
this is our Outpost Elgato
thank you
[Music]
for numbers
the massive expansion Monster Hunter
rise sunbreak will be released for these
platforms on April 28 2023.
you can look forward to a host of new
features including new monsters locales
and combat mechanics in addition to
memorable new characters and story lines
the expansion includes the free title
updates up to free Title Update 3 giving
you instant access to chaotic Gore
magala and other powerful monsters
we'll have information about future
updates at a later date
yeah
free title updates are also available
for monster hunter rise sunbreak for
Nintendo switch and steam
[Music]
we will host a monster hunter rise
sunbreak digital event in April to share
the latest information about the next
free title update 5.
[Music]
moving on to our next topic we have news
about the Resident Evil series
foreign
[Music]
Island
we're excited to share this new preview
with you all you may have noticed Jill
Valentine made a brief appearance at the
end of the video
Resident Evil death Island will release
this summer
[Music]
survival is just the beginning Resident
Evil 4 launches soon
[Music]
hello everyone I'm yoshiyaki hirabayashi
producer of Resident Evil 4. we're
grateful for all of the re4 fans who are
excited for the game's release this game
is a remake of the original which was
released in 2005.
it takes place six years after the
Raccoon City incident and depicts
federal agent Leon S Kennedy as he
fights to survive
our goal is to create a fresh yet
familiar experience we've preserved the
core of the original game and added
updated graphics and a reimagined
storyline
re4 has released it is just around the
corner but we have a special
announcement prepared for you today
please check out this video
[Music]
ah here we go
these guys don't quit
what the wait is over a trial version of
Resident Evil 4 that we are calling
chainsaw demo will be available starting
today
it takes place in the beginning of the
game as Leon first enters a European
Village the chainsaw demo has no time
limit and you can play it as many times
as you want the platform supported are
PlayStation 5 and Playstation 4 as well
as Xbox series X and Xbox series s and
steam we hope you enjoy trying a portion
of this reimagined survival horror
Resident Evil 4 is currently available
for pre-order
both the standard edition and the deluxe
edition include pre-order bonuses
sure to check them out
there's not long until the March 24th
release date please enjoy the trial
version until then
thank you for watching today
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
and finally we have a message about the
Capcom publisher sale the Resident Evil
series with the exception of the
upcoming Resident Evil 4 and Monster
Hunter rise are currently on sale and we
will be opening the massive expansion
Monster Hunter rise sunbreak for
pre-orders
don't miss this opportunity to pick up
digital copies of capcom's hits
[Applause]
that's all for our event today thanks
for watching
[Music]
we look forward to sharing more about
our latest titles through a future
Capcom Spotlight or Capcom showcase
thanks for watching see you next time
[Music]